all right Sam so you know I'm like if I
see a Warhammer game I'm gonna I'm gonna
at least give it a look
juices start flowing yeah but this this
is a what am i given I'm gonna try and
sell you on because I think it's for
both Warhammer fans and people who are
not quite as nerdy as it's me yeah so
the first thing you said was it's
Warhammer and I went hmm and then you
went by its Diablo Warhammer is
basically Diablo 3 set in the Warhammer
40,000 universe right and obviously the
w3 is a big game with a lot of lineage
and there's lots of parts of it that
different other games have ape and kind
of spun off what kind of Diablo like
experience are we getting out there for
people who perhaps need that as an entry
point but it's got the same like
visceral feel that you expect from a
Diablo game it's got the same approach
that like in Diablo you could min/max
your character and get really nitty
gritty or you could just get your
Templar and just go and smash that
nonsense out of zombies you've got best
of both worlds at the minute there's
three classes you've got the Crusader
who is kind of your tank class the
assassin which is your DPS glass cannon
sort of class and then your psycho which
we're seeing here which is kind of your
specialist kind of like the high-level
tricky class that you can do super cool
powers but like you're probably gonna
hurt yourself
it's it's like you can see it's zoom
lightning which is badass but if you're
it's one of those things that if you're
really into Warhammer it's it's got a
lot of the law of flavor behind it like
it can he can accidentally summon warps
born with his brain because he's
connected to the war really nerdy will
have my stuff but or if you just want to
play cool after a RPG all you need to
know is that this guy shooting lightning
and some of the flames around him and
cannon demons right so let's backtrack a
little they're like war hammers vast and
is known for having an insane amount of
history where does this thing take the
place like is it within the existing
Warhammer 40,000 lore is a different
part of it so it's connected to the the
Warhammer 40,000 law but Games Workshop
have given the guys making the game
their own sector in the galaxy so
they've been able to make like
an open world that they can kind of
crashed into their own they could make
their own storyline without kind of
interrupting on like the wider law so
it's it's very much connected and it's
very much about the same flavor factions
all the all the high level stuff that
you'd expect to see in the what happen
universe but it's also its own being so
you can jump into this not knowing
anything about Warhammer and slowly
you'll be like okay so the Inquisition
is there like demon hunters and heretic
hunters it drip feeds it to you quite
nicely and again like you can just be
attracted to the ability just to stomp
mines but for people who do one that
sorry like how is that parceled out to
you is it like a like an ambien thing
where you're just hearing people's
conversations reading Scrolls or is
there like specific missions that you're
being set so it's funny that you mention
I the the ambience thing because it's
connected to a lot of like that wider
Lord just you kind of nods to it and
character name drops but it's got its
own storyline about this own band of
inquisitors but the single-player
campaign is a single-player it's it's
not like Diablo in that instance where
you could play it all multiplayer this
is you you play as the campaign the bit
that you know it's going to deliver the
story you play that solo but then like
the purging missions the exploration the
time and events all of that can be
played into for black cop right and does
does your stats and character and that
kind of stuff carryover between those as
far as I know yeah everything you do in
the single-player campaign you can take
all that cool equipment you find into
multiplayer and Marines and everything
you find in multiplayer I've just if
you're struggling for a single-player
mission you go and knock around
multiplayer
so one of the things I like in these
type of games is like creating my own
version of a character bill that I
really like and customizing with
specific you know armor and abilities
and weapons in the castle so what's the
progression of characters like in this
is it going to be like when I go into my
player everyone has the same characters
or will be able to be like Lydon this is
my version of a coat and I play this
style it's very much the latter you
start off with the three core classes of
a crusader assassin seikar but you can
you a mold the character through
equipment you use so instead of
traditional RPGs the the abilities are
tied to class now there are tied to like
your weapons and you carry two weapons
at any time so the guy was saying now
he's gone Auto gun and the bottom left
you can see the abilities I switched the
sniper now the snipers abilities with a
sniper rifle
I like single shot blast shot headshot
and - but she's also got a pair of
pistols so if you switch weapons to your
pistols you'll have completely different
suite of abilities and you also have
your ultimate abilities and your armor
capabilities so the snipers armor that
just just happens to be the one that's
that's equipped it could be something
completely different if you find new
loot her ability is to summon
holographic clones to draw enemy fire
and to put out fire on to distract
enemies so you can build your psycho to
do one thing and then through leveling
up you can choose different perks you
can choose different passives different
equipment they can do something
completely different and the passives
are if you want a melee build you will
get passives by doing meta combat so you
can upgrade your melee passive by doing
50000 melee damage this is very much you
you you grow by by doing sort of things
you're shooting will get better the more
you Mellie will get better for you use
melee the grains will get better means
grace all right the the combat here
looks like is is it this is it like
different ways to play the game because
it seems like the character on screen
we're seeing is very much getting into
the thick of it like are there I assume
the classes in a lot of ways will make
up for ever like playing at range and
but is there stuff like cover and that
kind of stuff there's a there's a cover
system that you can use it's very good
for the for the
sniper keeping her range keeping her
safe but the cover is also destructible
so you need to write better in mind like
I can take cover pianos pillar for
example gives me gives me a nice cover
bonus the same way the 40k games do but
enemies can also use cover but the
environment is also super destructible
so if an enemy has taken cover behind a
pillar just drop the pillar on him and
in the pin level the falling debris will
do a bunch of damage to them as well but
this is this is the Titan this is
something I didn't even know was in the
game until the guys came and gave a demo
yesterday not Titan sorry an item like
wow someone's already someone is rage
typing alright night girl but the night
is basically a giant like 40 foot mech
nights piloted by a pilot that's just
wired into a machine and what you're
seeing on the screen these sentinels are
meant to be like bosses at the end of at
the end of loot runs and we were just
demolishing them with footsteps and this
just giant machine and they added this
into story but the community was like
hey don't don't tie this away behind
like missions that I can only play once
so they're also trying to incorporate
missions and wow that's that's natural
that you can replay and you know make a
master this giant iron so I think for
like people who are fans and people who
aren't watching this particular segment
one of the biggest questions they're
gonna have is is that laser coming out
with junk or not and it's coming out of
his arm there's no there's no junk
weapons okay they wear a nice glorious
Tabard of the house in which they
represent over the Titans I'm gonna
lights junk kind of want to see your
dick laser this I mean I mean if you
want dig lasers you're gonna have to
worship smash which is a very nerdy warm
reference that I hope someone out there
will recognize recover some cred with
that one like next question is gonna be
obviously the big thing for Diablo
especially is like post release content
and supporting it in the long run it's a
game that's still kind of alive and
kicking right now and I dip in and out
of it especially on the PC every now and
then
do they have plans to do the same thing
it seems like ripe for it I asked the
same question a RPGs they need the
lifespan of keep living content and they
are keen to add everything they said
everything that's in Warhammer 40k we
want in this game and at the minute
there's just the chaos faction
representing Nergal but they want more
factions in and they're doing this
through seasons just laughing noble
sounds like the nerd in the class flicks
boogers that is all mechanics literary
he's the play God all right but they're
doing these things called faction
seasons so after the release of the game
they will though there'll be a season
and this season could represent any
faction in the Warhammer universe so it
could be the season of The Tao
this isn't confirmed by the way this was
just this is just an example I flow you
ask them so it could be the season of
the towel the towel will come into the
galaxy in life and fit in their own
unique story missions then you can fight
a new enemy they'll have their own story
you'll get new equipment and all that
will be free and bearing in mind there's
like over ten more factions you can't
like different Kerris cards and stuff so
they could have way way more seasons and
way more content and the interesting
thing that they mentioned with this is
that the way the community beats the
seasons will influence the game world so
if you come across a world that's like
you can you can purge this world and
rebuild it into a vibrant new settlement
through like your Inquisitor doing stuff
or you can be like nah blow up do it
exterminators and just trash it if more
than like 50 percent of the players
decide to destroy that world the world
will become like a death world and I be
inhabited by demons it'd be like wastes
and disgusting and that will follow
moguls full of Naugles oven egglings
that will stay in the game world as that
death world because of the way the
players have decided to approach it so
slowly but surely different parts of the
set the sector in the galaxy will evolve
depending on how you how the player base
as a whole self quests right so despite
the lack of crotch lasers and the
inclusion of a booger flicking nerd look
a flick
like you know Katya this has managed to
pique my interest in I'm always looking
for a variant on Diablo you know once
you find the hablo you've never and
you're like one more Diablo likes games
it's the satisfaction of like running
around and without without even being a
40k fan I would o be into this because
it's got giant robots
you've got assassins that can turn
invisible yes you can hear the thud of
the ball guns and lasers being knocked
around everywhere demons floating about
it's just a fun time it's got that
visceral feeling of like manically
left-clicking on paper that's what we
that's what we're projecting on what we
want out of it right now this is still
in preview stage obviously yeah who
knows what the final game's gonna be
like if it you know managed to achieve
what the developers seem like they're
trying to it could be a really
interesting spin on the Diablos serious
I mean in the few months that I haven't
played it like I played it yesterday and
I played it in a much earlier version of
early access in September and I will say
like the early access version I played
was a little feature thin and a little
rough when it came to optimization when
I played yesterday played completely
fine looked great and they added a bunch
more stuff and they've really responded
to the changes the community want to see
and now like they surprised me because
they were saying that the it's leaving
early access and launch you on console
on the same day on the 11th of May Wow
so it's been like a super quick
turnaround right and I'm excited to play
more and I hope that you'll join me in
destroying the I think about it I think
about it alright well that's that's
that's my little nerd excitement over
Warhammer there's a martyr if you if you
enjoyed and your interest in the game
I'm so let us know in the comments
section below
but until the 11th of May just try not
to fall victim under any chaos gods I
guess I'll do my absolute best but I
can't promise anything